olivier duhamel politologue français a
été accusée d'inceste sur son beau-fils
par camille kouchner la soeur jumelle de
sa victime
cette révélation vous a d'ailleurs fait
réagir et vous vous demander de quelle
façon la justice peut intervenir
est ce que cette affaire est marginal si
le sujet toujours tabou l'inceste est
beaucoup plus courant qu'on ne le pense
alors quels sont les vrais chiffres de
l'inceste en france on y répond dans
fuck
d'abord qu'est-ce que l'inceste dans le
droit pénal
voici comment il est qualifié ce peut
être des crimes des viols ou des délits
d agression sexuelle ils peuvent être
commis par des ascendants le père et la
mère ou un grand parent mais aussi le
frère et la soeur un angle et une tante
ou un neveu et une nièce
il peut être aussi commis par le
conjoint d'une de ces personnes nous
militons depuis 20 ans pour que
l'inceste soit criminalisé comme un
crime spécifique
aujourd'hui c'est un viol incestueux une
agression sexuelle incestueuse
mais pas un crime spécifique la question
que l'on se pose alors est combien de
personnes en sont victimes
selon une enquête d'ipsos pour
l'association face à l'inceste
un français sur dix déclarent en avoir
été victime
c'est pour nous un chiffre qui
commençait à s'approcher de la réalité
par rapport aux chiffres internationaux
on est peut-être encore en dessous de la
réalité
et pourtant on estime qu'en moyenne deux
enfants par classe en sont victimes
mais la recette a bien du mal à être
exposé hors du cadre familial
retrouvez en fait une identité qu'avec
est complètement fracassé
par cette attaque du lien familial parce
que l'infraction est commis par la
personne qui est censé nous protéger
nous éduquer vous accompagner jusqu à
l'aja ne cessa la particularité en fait
nous l'inceste et c'est pour cette
raison d'ailleurs que c'est si difficile
a dénoncé par les deux des faits
d'inceste qui existe c'est faire
exploser quelque part les familles sur
laquelle repose notre société est
aujourd'hui on n'est pas prêt à ça selon
le plan pour lutter face aux violences
faites aux enfants chaque année plus de
165 mille d'entre eux subissent des
viols ou des tentatives de viol et la
majorité d'entre eux seraient incestueux
tout aussi inquiétant les personnes qui
déclarent avoir subi des actes
incestueux sont passées de 300 dépensés
en 2009 à 10 % en 2020 alors y at il une
augmentation de ces crimes et délits
plus tôt
libération de la parole lié à la vague
nuit tout grâce aussi aux réseaux
sociaux pour porter plainte
une victime d'inceste doit faire face à
plusieurs obstacles le premier est la
prescription le temps donné pour porter
plainte depuis 2018 il est passé de 20
ans à 30 ans après la majorité de la
victime
ce sujet fait débat dans la sphère
duhamel certains aimeraient que ce délai
n'existe plus y compris chez nos
lecteurs
moi je je prône la suspension de la
prescription
pendant l'année si tu ne suis pas pour
l'imprescriptibilité de des viols ou des
agressions sexuelles
parce que là prescriptive bilité dans
notre droit français pour le moment est
réservé à ce qu'on appelle le crime
contre l'humanité on s'est créé pour ça
pour supprimer la prescription qu'on
considère comme un passeport pour le
viol d'enfant
on s'est créé aussi pour abolir la
recherche du consentement de l'enfant
car le deuxième obstacle de taille et la
difficulté à rassembler des preuves
la victime doit prouver que son viol ou
son agression sexuelle a eu lieu soit
sous la contrainte la surprise la menace
ou la violence ces faits là ne se pas se
passe toujours dans l'intimité il ya
jamais témoin bien sûr le l'agresseur ne
va pas violées ou agressées sexuellement
l'enfant tout dans tout le monde donc ça
se fait
dans l'intimité dans la chambre de
l'enfant mais c'est vrai que dans piques
les affaires d'inceste quand elles
viennent y longtemps après les faits
évidemment l'épreuve de certaines
preuves matérielles et même lorsque ces
preuves sont rassemblés les victimes
peuvent être confrontés à un troisième
obstacle la correctionnalisation voici
ce qui se cache derrière ce terme
barbare
lorsqu'un violet jugé il doit l'être
devant une cour d'assises qui jugent les
crimes
mais pour désengorger cette cour il
arrive qu'ils soient jugés dans un
tribunal correctionnel qui juge les
délits
on transforme alors le viol en agression
sexuelle ou atteintes sexuelles en ne
mentionnant pas la pénétration
l'accusé risque alors une peine de dix
ans de prison maximum contre 20 ans aux
assises les victimes sont encouragés ou
manipulés points vers la
correctionnalisation on va dire en leur
nom que
que sait ce qu'elles veulent parfois
certains vont dire qu'elles ne sont pas
prêtes à à se confronter à une cour
d'assises trop impressionnante
j'ai un docile la queue gpd récemment au
mois de décembre
le juge d'instruction avait proposé la
correctionnalisation du dossier cabidos
client entend refuser la
correctionnalisation et je pense qu'on a
bien fait parce que cette qualification
criminelle correspondait à la réalité de
ce qui s'est passé pour mes clientes
pour obtenir justice
ces victimes doivent souvent passer par
un parcours du combattant
mais alors qui est concerné par
l'inceste
d'après les enquêtes ce sont 78 % de
femmes qui en sont victimes et 22 %
d'hommes l'inceste l'inceste est présent
dans tous les milieux sociaux croire que
ça ne l'est pas c'est un cliché c'est
par contre mieux cacher mieux protégés
dans les sphères plus élevé
socioprofessionnelles ce n'est pas une
question de moyens financiers c'est
plutôt une question de structure de
personnalités
[Musique]